Where should brentuximab be considered in patients with Hodgkin's disease?
Okay, here we go.
So, of course, brentuximab vedotin is an anti-CD30 antibody drug conjugate linked to monomethyl
orostatin E, disrupts the microtubule network, and targets CD30 on Hodgkin-Reeds terbrine
cells.
It has, on the right, three U.S. Food and Drug Administration approved indications for
use in Hodgkin disease and has been established over the last decade and a half, first in
the relapse setting, then in the post-transplant consolidation setting, and most recently
in the frontline treatment for advanced-stage disease.
So, on the left, the seminal echelon, one trial randomized over 1,300 patients with
advanced-stage classic Hodgkin lymphoma to BVAVD versus ABVD, and at the most recent
six-year follow-up, BVAVD demonstrated an overall survival benefit compared to ABVD
and replacing bleomycin-led.
So, on the right, the seminal echelon, one trial randomized over 1,300 patients with
advanced-stage classic Hodgkin lymphoma to BVAVD versus ABVD, and at the most recent
six-year follow-up, BVAVD demonstrated an overall survival benefit compared to ABVD.
So, on the left, the seminal echelon, one trial randomized over 1,300 patients with
advanced-stage classic Hodgkin lymphoma to BVAVD versus ABVD, and at the most recent six-year
follow-up, BVAVD demonstrated an overall survival benefit compared to ABVD.
So, on the right, the seminal echelon, one trial randomized over 1,300 patients with
advanced-stage classic Hodgkin lymphoma to BVAVD versus ABVD, and at the most recent six-year follow-up,
response rates and progression free and overall survival rates. And interestingly, is not only
feasible, but safe, even in individuals who are older and below in the 61 to 75 year range.
And then last, as we just got through discussing the new standard, at least in the United States
and elsewhere, Nivo AVD. But of course, there are still contexts where BV can and should be
considered, as was also alluded to. So the first scenario is an early stage unfavorable Hodgkin
lymphoma population for which combined modality therapy has shown a consistent but modest benefit
over chemotherapy alone. And two important trials to note are first the breach trial, where BV AVD
was given for four cycles, followed by 30 gray of involved node radiotherapy versus ABVD plus
radiation. And the primary outcome of this trial being interim pet CR rate was increased. However,
the overall survival outcomes like progression free survival were very similar. A separate US
phase two study attempted to address the role of radiation specifically in the with BV AVD
treatment, where individuals were all treated with BV AVD for four cycles, and then randomized to
one of three different radiation strategies, and a fourth strategy of observation without radiation
without radiation at all. So interestingly, two year progression free survival was similar,
irrespective of the radiation strategy. Multiple other non randomized studies have suggested that BV
containing regimens may have an important role in patients with bulky disease or other unfavorable
risk factors,
and may actually
obviate the need for radiation. However, these are not yet established standards of care. In addition, as we'll
discuss very shortly, there are a number of brentuximab based salvage regimens that can be used in either the
pre or post transplant setting with very high response rates and in many cases good tolerability. Now, one of the oldest indications and most well described is in the post
setting, according to the Athera trial, where individuals who were at high risk for relapse
were randomized to placebo or BP consolidation for up to 16 cycles. Five-year progression-free
survival was 59% with brentuximab versus 41% without. No overall survival benefit was seen,
however. Interestingly, only 14% of patients actually completed all 16 cycles of consolidation
therapy, but despite this, certain subgroup analyses have shown that two-year PFS was very
similar irrespective of whether patients received more than half of BV cycles or less than a half
and even up to a quarter of BV cycles. So the role of post-transplant BV is even a little bit
less clear when brentuximab has already been used in frontline treatment or salvage.
BV plus checkpoint inhibitors are increasingly being used as, at least theoretically,
BV-induced cell death may enhance PD-1 blockade and immune cell activity.
These can also be very effective in the elderly or those who are unfit for anthracycline-based
therapy, like individuals with low systolic function. For example, the BV-nevo plus doxorubicin-induced cell death is also very effective in the elderly or those who are unfit for anthracycline-based therapy, like individuals with low systolic function.
The, for example, the BV-nevo plus doxorubicin-induced cell death is also very effective in the elderly or those who are unfit for anthracycline-based therapy, like individuals with low systolic function.
For example, the BV-NEVO plus doxorubicin-dicarbazine regimen has an 88% complete response rate and an exactly similar 88% to your PFS in patients with early and advanced stage disease.
And on the right, the table summarizes the numerous BV-based regimens for elderly or infirm patients.
For example, BV-indicarbazine has shown so far the longest PFS at 47 months.
The brevity trial tested BV-monotherapy.
And in addition, individuals with reduced ejection fraction, low DLCO, demonstrable heart failure.
BV-NEVO without chemotherapy has an overall about 18 to 20-month PFS rate.
And BV-NEVO without chemotherapy has an overall about 18 to 20-month PFS rate.
Altogether, these demonstrate that BV does remain an important regimen for the elderly or unfit for intensive therapies.
So putting it all together, where should it be considered in 2026?
While the frontline therapy is pretty demonstrably NEVO plus ABD, BV interestingly does have the only overall survival benefit that has been demonstrated over chemotherapy, though I don't think that that will be for much longer.
In addition, the selection depends on context and, as was discussed, the key exclusion criteria from 1A26, like autoimmune disease.
And while Hodgkin as a post-transplant lymphoproliferative disorder is an uncommon situation, it could also be a consideration for BB-based therapies.
Of particular and perhaps most relevance is intolerances like autoimmune hepatitis, where in those situations, especially for high-grade AEs, you could consider switching from nevo-AVD to BB-based therapy.
And then in other settings, as we're about to discuss, as a salvage treatment, and then perhaps increasingly relevant with uptake of nevo-AVD, how it might be used as consolidation or salvage after transplant.
That's it.
So thank you very much, and we'll head to our last talk.